We would now like to use
Newton's second law to relate
impulse to change in momentum.
So again, let's
look at our set up.
We have an object
m, a velocity V,
and, let's say, here the
picture as t initial.
And we have some
initial velocity.
And then a little bit later
in time, we have time t final.
The moment the
velocity has changed.
And that's because throughout
this time interval,
we're applying an impulse.
We can call this
the i hat direction.
Now recall that our
definition of impulse,
it's a vector quantity.
It's equal to the
integral of the force.
Now when I write force
of t, I mean force
as a function of time.
And that's our dummy
variable t prime.
It's not force times time, but
force is a function of time.
And we're integrating
from the initial
to the final time period.
Now here's where
we use the second--
the version of
Newton's second law,
which is that force causes
the momentum of an object
to change.
So we can write this integral t
prime t initial, t prime equals
t final of dp dt.
I'll just make a
note that we've now
applied Newton's second
law, and because we're using
our dummy variable dt prime
And you can see that the
two dt primes cancel.
And this just
becomes the integral
from t initial t prime
to t final of dp.
And this is a pure differential.
And so we end up with impulse
is the momentum at t final minus
the momentum at t initial.
Now recall, this is
a vector integral.
But a vector integral is
just three separate intervals
for each component.
So each component of impulse
satisfies this equation.
For instance, the x
component of impulse
is how the x component of
momentum is changing in time.
Now generally, when we
write a final momentum
in our final state minus the
momentum during initial state,
we can call this the
change in momentum.
So down here, we would have
change in the x direction.
And so in conclusion, we
now have an integral way
of casting Newton's second law.
We have that impulse
causes momentum to change.
And so we can see that
the si units of impulse
are the same as the
si units of momentum,
which we saw before was
kilogram meter inverse seconds.